Do you consider yourself a fan of dogs?
Or cloud ice cream?
Well, it's episode 47 of IMG!
This is a mirror and this is clear glass.
A broccoli tree house and, with the right
outline, Europe can be a dragon.
In the early 1900s, Arthur S. Mole and John
D. Thomas took photos of thousands of American
soldiers standing in shapes from atop a tower.
Here they are as the Statue of Liberty.
In the front, there are 17 men.
The men in the torch are a half mile away and
of the 18,000 men arranged into this shape,
12,000 of them are in the torch.
The photographers also got people to stand
in the shape of Uncle Sam, President Woodrow
Wilson and a panther.
Subaru backwards is Ur A Bus and this piece
of furniture is actually a cake.
But this storm trooper?
Well, he's also a cake.
If you were a lot of rings, you can make your
fist Pac-Man.
And a stereographic projection projects a
sphere onto a flat plane.
A complete 360 degree view gets wrapped up
in a circle.
Josh Summers makes some of my favorites.
It's as if everything you can see from where
you're standing becomes its own planet.
Bongiovanni's paintings of birds look like
reality is melting.
But Takeshi Kawano's melting animal sculptures
are even more liquid-y.
Lots of things will melt when our Sun dies.
At first, it will expand and become a red
giant, eventually swallowing the Earth.
As water boils away, we will be left with
this - what Earth would look like without water.
And this is what Mars would look like with water.
But Niagara Falls without water?
Well, it's happened.
In 1969, the army core of engineers dammed
the river to strengthen some faults and slow
its erosion.
Lay on the ground and take a photo straight
down to put yourself in cool positions.
And here's a map of a global subway system.
Buzzfeed collected 9 pictures of cats wrapped
up like burritos, but for the montage let's
take a look at forever alone?
Nailed it.
Nails bent into different situations by Andrei Nikolaev.
When you're this happy, your eyes are actually
drooling smiley faces.
Oh, and this cat's mouth is an angry bunny.
Wow, well, at least dogs haven't enslaved
kids yet.
Oh.
Bruce Lowell sources LEGO parts and creates
fantastic items.
A taco, a sandwich or a LEGO paint effect.
This painting is also an effect.
The woman is a real person.
Alexa Meade uses acrylic paint on people's
bodies to make them look like paintings of
themselves.
These people aren't painted, but they don't
know each other.
I've always loved this project.
Artist Richard Renaldi walks around and finds
total strangers out in public.
He then asks them, despite the fact that they
don't know each other, to pose for photos
as if they were close friends or lovers.
Strangers also touch when cartoon characters
are placed in famous paintings.
And here are some hipster Disney princesses.
Or, the princesses as super heroes.
Oh, remember those living photographs of soldiers?
Another type of living photograph is this.
Many YouTube videos are quick paced and jump
cut every 4 seconds, but living photographs
do the opposite.
The subject poses for minutes, like when you're
taking a picture of someone but forget you're
in video mode.
Watching is kind of amazingly awkward.
And the cloth wrapped around these trees lines up
with the mountains in the distance, which,
my friends, is artwork.
And as always,
thanks for watching.